the Joe Rogan experience that's one of
the reasons why I bring people on that I
don't agree with I think it's important
to have conversations with people where
they're on the left or the right that
you don't agree with just to find out
who they are and what they think yeah
and just to have discussions also like
testing your own feelings about my son
just like okay no that's that's alright
I still feel having heard arguably their
best argument or a very cogent argument
for their side and you go yep I think
that I think the the thing that is lost
in our in one of the things that's lost
in the world now is because of I
partially because of the internet or
blog or whatever where you have to be a
hundred percent in every belief and it's
like I'm not a hundred percent in any
belief no like I'm like I there are some
beliefs where I say I'm 50 then I'm 51%
and but that still wins 51% is still the
thing I tell you where if people can't
believe you either got to be a hundred
percent right or zero or a [ __ ] or
you're a [ __ ] stud like and there's
no like yeah what abortion is a perfect
example where we're both like I'm for it
but but it's pretty brutal
or it's pretty it's a severe thing or
whatever the but and you're not allowed
to have a butt anymore can't you just
can't go I have a measured point of view
and it's I took the vote in my head and
it's 70/30 yeah or not and it can change
your mind some learner that's bad that's
my some one said well not just one
person many people said you flip-flop on
things like no I I consider things yeah
and it's not it's also not when
politicians do it it's because they it's
politically in their gonna work in their
favor yes you do it because you've
thought more about it or you heard the
right argument at the right time okay
yeah I changed my opinions all the time
I don't I don't I'm not married to those
[ __ ] things I don't need them you
know my opinions are just the ideas in
my mind or something that should be
explored and there's certain ideas that
I just hold stuff
said fat don't rape don't murder people
don't steal all the obvious ones yeah
everybody holds those yeah but then when
it gets too unusual weird slippery
things I'm like okay well what is why is
there an inclination to lean towards a
certain direction like what we virtue
signaling or yeah you know we are
sending out the the flag of tribal
obedience yeah but what are we doing
when we're discussing these things and a
lot of that is what ruins discourse and
this is what I think I have a real big
problem with deep platforming we start
deep platforming people and censoring
people you don't just want to not hear
them you want no one to hear them and
this is where I have a problem it's cuz
oh who the [ __ ] are you like why are you
the one who gets to say even if they're
wrong even if they're one let everybody
figure that it's misinformation that's
the thing it's like pizza Gator one of
the third like the right Alex dude what
the [ __ ] are you doing heats a gate is a
good example right because people get
ramped up in it like what and there was
that guy Ben Swan who was a journalist
who had all these he was he had this
video that he put out that showed like
all the different connections with
conspiracy theory or with pizza gate and
various conspiracies and pedophilia and
it was it was a real weird one it was
like what's just because these things
are the similar it doesn't mean there's
a pedophile ring going on they're like
what is that what exact exactly is
happening there but then you hear about
someone like Jimmy Savile and you go
wait a minute wait what this guy was
[ __ ] kids for how long yeah and no
one like how are there any other ones
right now that they have it exposed yeah
you know what I mean like that kind of
that kind of [ __ ] does
I don't yeah having yeah I I think
there's a big there's a ton of distance
between there are pedophiles and there
are pedophiles in the pizza place in the
basement yeah like there I believe
there's pedophiles right and that they
should be stopped and they're mostly and
I might bet it I don't think none of
them are powerful and that but I don't
think that there is a I just don't
really buy into conspiracy just
generally so I buy in a some
because there's some of them that are
provable there's some of them that it
really did happen where you go Jesus
Christ they really did that there's no
yeah I mean like like with like men in
like third world countries where will
[ __ ] with elections like seven the [ __ ]
like that like that is yeah like that's
not even a conspiracy that's just like a
poorly told part of history that's all
those things Howard's all [ __ ] hongcun
is right oh yeah yeah yeah but that's I
think that's well I think that's out
yeah you know domain
oh yeah do you know about the operation
Northwoods do you know about that one I
don't know that one's probably the most
disturbing one because that one was
signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff they
were going to organize a bunch of
attacks on America and blame the Cubans
so that we could go to war with Cuba
yeah we're gonna arm people from yes and
have them attack want Onam obeyed they
were gonna blow up a jet liner and blame
it on Cuba they had all these plans and
it was signed by the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and then vetoed by Kennedy was
like what the [ __ ] are you what were you
guys doing you guys so I went to [ __ ]
the Hyannis Port and I come back he's
trying to blow up airplanes and the
thing is it's this is something that
didn't fly but we found out about it how
many of these things we didn't find out
about that actually did happen yeah and
that we think are legitimate instances
in the news or real attacks yeah I just
think it's a drop in the bucket I should
drop in the bucket I think it's less
than 1% comparison to actually the
actual reality person I agree yeah and
so when when people are the reason I
don't like conspiracy theories I think
it people use it to explain their own
failure a lot of the time like we see it
a lot in comedy like well you can't make
it unless you're a good being like all
right I don't work yet I hate that
[ __ ] that perspective is so crazy
it's like listen if you're killing
people are gonna see you if you kill a
lot people go to see you a lot yeah it's
not something you can't fake it is a
meritocracy it really is is and it's
like there are there are certainly like
some quota of stuff in the margins
mm-hmm but not no one's making it no
one's doing arenas because of a quota
you can't pull yeah there's nothing you
can do to get into arenas yeah people
have to actually like
you
[Applause]